the important thing to know about this
crisis and that had happened in the
1930s is that in order to get the checks
that we're needing you know a lot of
people a lot of companies need checks
now where will they those checks come
from so they'll be checks from the
government the type of support we're
going to receive is two types of support
where's this all this money come from so
that the government when they say I'm
gonna pay more for unemployment
insurance or I'm going to give you a
loan for a small business or so on they
where they're they get the money from
well they've either tax it but if they
tax it that's bad so the government they
can borrow it that's what a deficit is
the government runs a deficit and then
the question is who's going to borrow it
when everybody's financially strapped
and the Federal Reserve says they have
the power to print money and they will
say I will borrow it and I will lend you
the money so the Federal Reserve is
lending the money and it is also lending
others the money all right yes when when
they print money are they literally
sending a Brinks truck with bags full of
cash and distributing it through local
banks no money is digital okay so there
are they're really just making ledger
adjustments in a digital file somewhere
right the important thing to know is
that all that we think about money is
not limited in any way like there's a
certain amount of money out there it's
all make-believe it's all digital so
they could change the digits and then
they can create money now that's an
important consideration because if they
can create money so easily how do we
know it's going to be a value when
they're creating a lot of it that's one
of the considerations that are being
faced today but the main thing to know
about this yeah stepping back for the
big picture
is that every individual every company
and every government has certain amount
of money that comes in in the form of
income a certain amount of expenses that
and then a certain amount of savings so
you do individually and every all your
listeners do and it works the same way
for everyone so that if their income
falls and then gret less to be less than
their expenditures they're in trouble
unless they have a good savings and then
they go to the savings so all around the
world there are lots of entities that
are in trouble
in that way so the government the two
parts of the government the US
government two parts want to give checks
to people now it's difficult to decide
who gets it who doesn't get it but if
they don't give checks to people or to
companies those will go bankrupt because
they may not have enough savings so you
you saw j.crew went bankrupt just went
bankrupt and you'll see others go
bankrupt because they don't have enough
and so when they go bankrupt and that's
a whole other process so in order to
prevent that they have to give money and
so they print money we call it print
there's not even paper much it's
digitally create money and then that
comes in the form of loans so what we're
going through is the same process has
happened in the 1930 to 1945 period so
as I was saying there are three
important things that is one the second
is large wealth gap third is that we
have a rising power in the form of China
emerging to compete or challenge the
United States leadership so when you
have these three things together it's
it's a challenging mix and it's happened
repeatedly less effective monetary and
credit system makes it they have to
print a lot of money can threaten the
value of money
second when you have a large wealth gap
and you have an economic downturn people
are more inclined to have conflict so
how that's dealt with we're going to
reconsider how we're going to that
wealth will be divided and that'll
change taxes and relationships and then
the third is we're no longer in a world
order where the United States is the
only dominant power these three things
existed and the most important things
existed and then we had the downturn
terms in terms of the virus so you could
think of the virus like being a tsunami
that came and if it went and if we had
not no more of it it still would have
left a lot of economic damage so you in
all different ways so the the economic
damage has to be understood and dealt
with people that are familiar with
finance and financial institutions and
how the economy works and all that
they'll find their way through this but
for the average person who doesn't
understand a lot of this what can the
average person take away from that they
don't have bonds they don't think like
that they may not even understand what
their 401k is or they may not even have
a 401k so how do they navigate this is
it just head down do your best to
weather the storm or is there actually
something that they can learn from the
historical perspective and move on now
to make this easier for them the first
is look at your income your expenses and
your savings and then do a stress test
so that you get yourself secured if you
were to lose your income or if the
income were to fall beyond
a certain level and you play that out
maybe that means you go get unemployment
insurance burger or whatever how long
can you live in an acceptable lifestyle
and do you have a savings that is
adequate for that okay so what you do is
you calculate if I lived in a simpler
lifestyle and I had this amount of
earnings how many months how many months
or years could I live acceptable then
you look at your what what do you put
the money in what do you save it 1929 to
32
interest rates hit zero they print money
we had a large wealth gap and then they
sat down and they figured out how do we
keep it orderly and how do we change the
circumstances with whether it's taxes or
how do you realized it so that the
system works well there is a risk also
at the same time because the world is
going through that there's a risk of
conflict so in Germany Hitler came in
power in 1933 and he came in power in
1933 because there was a lot of internal
fighting as to to try to bring produce
order because that everybody the left
and the right you know the Communists
and the fascists and they're all
fighting about wealth because
everybody's fighting without wealth when
you have a downturn and then they need
the they were democracies for
democracies existed then that chose not
to be democracies because they became so
disorderly that they wanted some strong
leader to take charge and run the
country and then of course we had a
bunch of straw those types of leaders
and then they had a war that's how world
war 2 happened so when you look at that
you know though that's kind of the
political landscape but back to the
average man in terms of his finances I
would say the import
thing is those three elements to have a
plan and maybe to have a plan with both
your family you know how do you get down
when things got tough and and you know
and then you have to look at you know
what happens in policy
well policy is or it depends on the
person some people would understand more
about policy than other people if if you
know so it depends on what they should
do it depends on what they're able to do
well I think your audience ranges from
you know there's a wide range that you
have in your audience and I would say
that there are many people in your
audience who can plan for a simple
lifestyle that can be wonderful
sometimes we acquire these needs that
aren't at anywhere near as big as as we
make them out to be and you know do you
have a bed to sleep in do you have food
to eat do you have basic health care
okay if you start to think okay what are
my needs that I really need and on okay
and how can I make provisions for those
needs then once you've got that in your
mind you're you're free okay you you can
go beyond that you know that you may say
listen oh I can do that for a year or
two years or a month or whatever but you
I think we visualize too much the things
that we're used to one of the good
things about this exercise is that you
can bring it brings you back to basics
you can be brought to basics and like
I'm saying if you have a bed to sleep it
and you've got food and so on and you
have those basics and good relationships
with people who care about you in basic
health care so if you budget for that
and you figure how do you have it maybe
it isn't in the luxurious
place your in maybe it's in the country
and so on
once you visualize that and you get that
doubt in your head and you say oh I can
get that then your stress will disappear
because you as you visualize that in
many ways that's a happy life it doesn't
take a lot to there's stimulation
there's nature there's relationships
these fundamental wonderful things the
most important things can be obtained
and so for many of you I think if you
look at that and you budget for that I'm
seeing a number of people who are going
broke and and I've watched this over
many years and really it's just the
adjustment process one that once they
get to that point where ah you know they
have they get settled they're fine
it's the ambiguity it's the worry it's
the stress so if you do that from the
beginning and you have that that played
out in your head then you know
everything from there you can play with
and it's you're it's icing on the cake
you know I want to emphasize you can
budget for that you could look at that
find that scenario find what that looks
like so that you know you got it down
then you know you're safe once you've
got safe everything beyond that is
luxury if you want more advice wisdom
guidance from other successful
entrepreneurs on how you can navigate
the coronavirus situation check out the
video right there next to me I hope you
find it valuable continue to believe and
I'll see you there the exact things
people need to be obsessively focused
with right now